as many things about this story in this
role that that were very dear to me and
sort of close close to me when I
embarked on the journey of creating this
character but one of the most glaring
sort of obstacles was the fact that i'm
not in fact from india i haven't lived
there extensively I my father's Indian
but my mother's Italian and I grew up in
London so I knew that there was a
certain amount of work that I would need
to do in order to be able to portray
this sort of iconic Bombay boy Salim and
so yeah I went to India first for about
a month in the late summer of two
thousand nine we ended up we shot in
2010 from februari through May pretty
much on a crazy shoot with 65 unit
shifts in 70 days it was a it was a real
real rollercoaster but I spent a month
in india first studying hindi traveling
around bombay and sort of really trying
to you know in a way develop a
storehouse of memories or of like
experiences because i had never been on
my own terms sort of in india i'd been
there with parents and for family
occasions stuff like that so yeah so um
I was there for a month and then went
back about two three months before we
started shooting and traveled quite a
bit and spent a lot of time studying
Hindi and walking around and watching
movies and reading everything about the
history which was another thing that I
was sort of vaguely you know I was
familiar with loosely but unsurprisingly
growing up in England they don't teach
you all that much about Indian history
so I I that was a big sort of crash
course as well academically in a way and
I read you know lots of books both about
partition and you know leading up to
partition but also and sometimes even
more interestingly about India in the
last sort of 60 years since independence
so so yeah it was a large large research
mission really to try and get inside the
head of this character initially I was
familiar with the novel I had read it
when
quite young but it was it wasn't I
hadn't read it sort of right before
meeting with Deepa certainly when we
first met it was more of a social the
social meeting I was in Toronto working
on another film and we had recently done
a play with someone she had worked with
and so we just sort of met as you do and
went out for lunch um but then once it
became clear to me that she was
considering me for this part I I drove
back into the book and sort of
coincidentally i started reading it on
rereading it on like a friday and i got
a call friday afternoon saying that i'd
be meeting with salman on monday so i
was like oh my god 600 pages in one
weekend but i like burned through the
whole thing again and and so yeah I
spoke with someone then and at that
point they was really it was you know
over a year and a half before we started
shooting so they were still working on
the script they even actually had I
think they had just decided not to make
it to films but the one of the original
sort of thoughts was to have it be a two
part movie and so then we spoke we spoke
at length about sort of our own
relationship to Bombay and you know
different families and the process of
that adaptation and that was pretty much
the only time we spoke we emailed a
little bit but then pretty soon
afterwards it became sort of clear that
my channel of discussion was deeper and
I spoke to her a lot and she was in
touch with Salman but he wasn't like you
know dealing day-to-day with the actors
at all and wasn't on set and so then I
would go back to the book I mean
constantly I had it you know have this
like threadbare copy that would
practically sleep on you know sleep with
it under my pillow I have always always
attached to it yeah they've really you
know deeper and someone and you know
Colin who's the editor have really
managed to sort of keep the in a way the
more historical moments feel I sometimes
feel like the more historical moments
feel a little bit more immediate and
personal for example I think about that
shot of General Zulfikar right before he
surrenders wiping his shoe you know in a
small room and some of the
emotional interpersonal moments are
treated in a more epic way you know
you've got the you know lovers reuniting
in the rain which is like an old sort of
deep azam aaj to like an old bollywood
trope which is the lovers sort of
falling in love and crying and kissing
in the rain so I think that yeah you
know I mean one we screen this film at
Telluride almost a year ago a little
under but um and you know terrorists up
one Street so you can't help but hear
what everybody's saying about all the
movies is you're like walking around and
I heard somebody say that it was like
the indian forest gump so i think that
that that is a film that also sort of
ties together certain aspects of a
country's history and also the history
of a character